みなさんこんにちは
太りました被ってより太りまして僕大勢がです昔ずっと65キロをキープしてたんです
けども
いつから妥協できたら去年からなぜか体重が異常に増えてしまう
わかんない年齢のせいなのかわかんないんですけどすごい最近体重が落ちないというか
1回にすごいダイエットしたじゃないですか60何キロまで落ちたんですけどさっき
ちょっと困ったググってあってきて気づい
いたらもう70キロぐらいずっとキープしてるんですよちょっと乗ってみましょう
野望 d ぶー
いやほんとにちょっとマジでせめて65 k ケープで一体ロックス動きだけでがなく
すぐちょうどいいする不可能だったんでちょっと音抜けられ痩せないと思います若干肉
がついてきちゃってるかなって今日するんでどれだけ何とかこう減らしていきたいなと
思っておりますあの普通走っても前へ成長にするんですけどそれだと効率が悪いという
的にもっとこう汗をかいて体の
毒素とが排出するために鼻栓つみなさん使ったことありますでしょうか
こちらですね汗の量こんな性格のこれを着ると多分結構汗が出るんだと思います簡単に
ダイエットような騒がせずですねこれ
重ね着したら効果が倍になるんでねってことで8枚準備しましたこれいく受けるはず
ないの効果があるということで
普通で8倍の汗がかける
じゃないかなと思いましてなんか短距離でもすごいやってるじゃんっていう天性的発想
に用いたわけですよ
していきます
うわぁ
download なるほどこういう感じか
全然なく汗は出そうですけどやっぱり1枚だと4倍ですね
持っ重ねてくださいん
[音楽]
ブーブーちょっとしたらどうするだけでも普通に動く
パーツば犬ふっ
素晴らしい曲名脱臭と800メートル走ったぐらいの何かあ食器されるネイキッド
[音楽]
ブーブーけどリーグ第4
家ってどれくらいの影響がてるの方もわからないんでとりあえず走ってみようと思い
ますじゃあ
出てきます
でももっとほどきつくないぞこれ生き抜いてしかし年生
すごいキツくっ
やばいやばいやばいん
par
ちょっと待ってください
やばすぎるーっ
はぁああああああん
だいたい100m くらい走ったんですけどねっ
心臓偉大さなんでだそんなの運動不足だけではないと思うんですけどすごい苦しいすぐ
ちゃくちゃ
冊を理解しています
me
ぶっせん
penang
car
ええええええ
ash
ウツボで出土人
ん
ああああああ
me
頭走っ私の前に何か生き物的な危機を感じませんだまだ汗与えてないようなちょっと
もうちょっと頑張ってみます
wh
tee
dj ん
平和生きても無理無理走れな柱だ
嘘で歩かせくださいちゃってるん
山って本当にすごいこれ束させちゃ駄目ですね走るの心臓の負荷がちょっと走ってる
だけでは多分全力疾走の感覚に陥るんだと思います
想像以上だな
wh
car
me
しまってしまってるはぁ
goo
待って八橋いないうーん
知っていますね
[拍手]
こんにちはさあ今寝ちゃんっ
ん言えたら者ら別の日トップのか作って気をつけてる
安部止めねばいばいん
[音楽]
あら今日はめちゃ生ズア
して何枚か
はぁ
を支えられません
ええええええ
ムーディー
wata
ん
me
肺臓いうわけで400m ぐらい走ったんですけどもう四尺で多分上です
心臓が痛いしじゃあ最後サイズを測りましょう
[音楽]
やばいやばいまずやばいやばいびっしょりびっしょり日したりこんなにってくれませ
回復やバーこんなに書いてたら実はこれ仕事が出てきますよ
マジだ
まっすぐじゃあどうぞ
どんな被害でのん
気になると以上ですうん約 h キュレーター
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ